[Música]
indignación en akron Ohio por la muerte
de jaylan Walker un hombre afroamericano
que falleció después de que ocho
policías le dispararon decenas de veces
el video de su muerte se publicó este
domingo y el alcalde lo define como
desgarrador
la derogación del programa Quédate de
México cobijará a los integrantes de la
más reciente caravana que partió desde
latinoamérica hacia Estados Unidos ahora
podrán esperar a que su situación se
resuelva mientras permanecen el suelo
norteamericano
la contaminación golpea a manaos la
ciudad más grande de la amazonía
brasileña ha visto como en las últimas
semanas sus aguas se han llenado de
basura son sobre todo residuos
reciclables que se suman a otros
inconvenientes que ya azotan esta región
selvática
Bienvenidos a esta emisión informativa
con las noticias más destacadas del
continente americano yo soy juanpupiales
comenzamos en Estados Unidos porque la
policía de akron en ohion difundió un
vídeo que muestra como un grupo de ocho
policías disparó hasta su muerte allílan
Walker una afroamericano de 25 años que
había oído de un control de tráfico el
cuerpo de Walker presenta más de 60
heridas de bala y según las autoridades
no estaba armado en el momento en que
empezó a correr este nuevo capítulo de
abuso policial ha generado indignación
en el país Alba Santana nos amplía
huir de un control de tráfico le costó
la vida a la afroamericano jaylan Walker
cuando al menos 8 agentes de policía de
akron Ohio le dispararon decenas de
veces causando al menos 60 heridas de
bala al hombre de 25 años
no hay duda de que el video que acabamos
de ver es extremadamente inquietante y
despertará muchas emociones y
sentimientos es impactante y difícil de
asimilar Y es que a pesar de que la
policía asegura que dispararon desde el
coche de Walker mientras suya este iba
desarmado cuando lo asesinaron
Quiero agradecer al teniente por una
cosa que dijo en el momento en el que le
dispararon más de 60 90 veces sea la
cifra que sea iba desarmado
n no era un criminal
estaba claramente sufriendo
no merecía morir un hecho que ha causado
indignación y protestas contra el
racismo
ya que este es el último de los muchos
asesinatos de hombres negros a manos de
la policía estadounidense un fenómeno
que los expertos tachan de racista e
injustificado
era probablemente una de las personas
más positivas que he conocido Así que
cuando me enteré de la noticia fue como
pensé que se habían equivocado con los
nombres
me duele cada día el hecho de
despertarme y saber que ya no puedo
hablar con él ahora a la oficina de
investigación criminal de Ohio está
llevando a cabo una investigación
independiente que durará varias semanas
y de momento los policías Implicados En
el tiroteo están de baja administrativa
Esperanza Esa es la palabra con la que
los migrantes rumbo a Estados Unidos ven
el futuro tras la cancelación del
programa conocido como quédate en México
a medida que permite a estas personas
esperar a que su situación se resuelva
en suelo norteamericano beneficiará a
los miembros de la más reciente caravana
migrante Rafael Pérez nos cuenta más
fin del programa de protección al
migrante o mpp por sus siglas en inglés
la iniciativa creada por el ex
presidente estadounidense Donald Trump
en 2019 tenía como objetivo evitar el
aumento del flujo migratorio instaurada
para quienes solicitaban asilo obligaba
a esperar el transcurso de los trámites
en territorio mexicano
que ya Fue cancelado posiblemente
primeramente Dios ya todo sea un poco
más rápido los procesos procedimiento
para todos nosotros Porque es muy duro
puede estar acá por la Corte Suprema de
Justicia de Estados Unidos negó un
recurso a los estados de Texas y
Missouri que pedían mantener el programa
que atentaba incluso contra la
integridad de quienes esperaban en
México más accesibilidad a que el
migrante pueda sí pedir su asilo
político ordenado digno humano
respetuoso como es verdad y esperar allá
donde hay más seguridad donde hay más
este derechos y que en un momento dado
va se pueda respetar la vida y la
dignidad de los migrantes la cancelación
del mpp supone una esperanza para los
miembros de la última caravana migrante
conformada por miles de personas la
aglomeración se disolvió este sábado la
entrega de permisos de estancia temporal
a Pequeños grupos en la oficina
migratoria de Huixtla hace que no todos
salgan al tiempo rumbo Norte
a tres meses de las elecciones
presidenciales en Brasil los dos
principales candidatos el actual
mandatario Yair bolsonarok y el ex
presidente Luis Ignacio y lulada Silva
realizaron mitines de frente a sus
seguidores las encuestas dan como
favorito a la izquierda da Silva quien
incluso podría ganar en primera vuelta
de acuerdo con los sondeos Marina
sardina con los detalles
dos inicios de campaña muy distintos
pero separados por unos pocos kilómetros
el sábado el ex presidente y candidato
presidencial doblada Silva se dio un
baño de masas en Salvador de bahía
coincidiendo con el día de su
independencia a los colonizadores a tres
meses de los comicios presidenciales en
Brasil
cualquier vista parte como favorito
según los sondeos con el 47% de
intención de Voto encontramos
lo vemos como nuestro presidente quizás
la figura pública viva más importante de
la historia de Brasil y es imposible no
emocionarse con sus palabras y No
dejarse guiar por este horizonte de
esperanza
rodeado por una multitud de
motociclistas y su esquema de seguridad
el presidente Yair bolsonaro se subió a
su moto para saludar a sus seguidores
bolsonaro se lanza la reelección con un
28% de intención de votos según las
encuestas algo que ha disparado las
alarmas en la campaña del líder
ultraderexista que deja el país con una
inflación del 12% desempleo del 10% y 33
millones de personas pasando hambre
para mostrar que estamos apuntando a la
reelección de nuestro presidente Yahir
Mesías bolsonaro y necesitamos esta
reelección de nuestro presidente
se espera que el próximo 2 de octubre se
decida al futuro de la presidencia en
Brasil de momento las encuestas
pronostican que luladas Silva podría
vencer en primera vuelta
manaos la mayor ciudad de la amazonía
brasileña sufre de un grave problema de
contaminación que ha empeorado estas
últimas semanas sus arroyos y canales
están llenos de basura emanando un olor
a veces insoportable un problema que
podría mejorarse con más concientización
de la población Gabriel colchen con los
detalles
se acumula tonta basura en estos canales
que a veces cubren la totalidad de la
superficie del agua en manaos Brasil
toneladas de residuos flotan en Los
Arroyos botellas plástico e incluso
electrodomésticos
la gente que vive en las afueras de la
ciudad también tira sucias residuos
directamente a Los Arroyos no hay mucha
gente que los deposita en el contenedor
alrededor del 20% creo como puedes ver
apesta verdad los trabajadores
municipales recogen 30 toneladas de
basura por día residuos que en su
mayoría Son reciclables en las últimas
semanas las autoridades han observado
que la situación empeoró la prefectura
la prefectura está haciendo su parte
pero Desafortunadamente la población
todavía tiene que encargarse de este
cuidado también porque todos estos
residuos aquí pueden contaminar nuestro
río negro nuestro río negro es muy
importante en nuestra ciudad la
concientización de la población es
esencial para preservar la naturaleza
que rodea manaos la ciudad está situada
en el medio de la amazonía brasilera y
bordea el río negro un afluente del río
Amazonas un riesgo de contaminación para
la mayor selva tropical del mundo que ya
sufre por la degradación y la
deforestación las selvas son los
pulmones del planeta ya que absorben los
gases a efectos invernaderos sin embargo
según la revista nature climent change
la amazonia brasilera ahora emite más
carbono que lo que absorbe
terminamos con las marchas del orgullo
que se vivieron este domingo en Caracas
y Bogotá para cerrar este mes de
conmemoraciones y reivindicaciones por
parte de la comunidad
lgbtiq más en la capital venezolana
fueron miles los que salieron a las
calles para pedir unos derechos
equitativos y expresar su rechazo a
cualquier forma de discriminación esto
en una nación en donde un hombre
homosexual tiene prohibido donar sangre
Mientras tanto en Colombia la la séptima
una de las arterias de la capital
cafetera acogió también a una multitud
que además conmemoró cuatro décadas
desde la primera movilización diversa en
esta ciudad
que no respeten como que no somos Ni más
ni menos personas simplemente por tener
gustos diferentes o por tener una
expresión de género diferente que
realmente nosotros no estamos imponiendo
nada sino que simplemente estamos
intentando normalizar lo que somos que
nos que nos vean no como un grupo sino
que nos vean como parte de toda la
humanidad todos somos iguales somos
personas
terminamos Así esta emisión informativa
quédense en nuestra pantalla también en
France 24.com
[Música]